the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
thank you all for coming I'm glad to see
that our attendance after the first
lecture is not dropped dramatically a
little bit that's to be expected but so
far I haven't managed to scare you all
off so this is the second lecture of the
signal processing on database course the
the format of the lecture will be the
same as as the last one we'll have some
slide material that will cover you know
the first half of the course and then
we'll take a short break and then
there'll be some example demo programs
and so with that we'll get into it and
all this material is available in your
ll grid accounts in the tools directory
you get a directory like this and the
documents the slides are right here so
we'll go to lecture 01
for those of you who aren't there or to
recap for those who will be viewing this
on the web later title the course is
signal processing on databases to terms
that we often don't see together the
signal processing element is really
alluding to detection theory and the
deeper serve linear algebraic basis of
detection theory the databases is really
alluding to unstructured data data that
we often represent with strings and
words and those denne denne sort of
sparse relationships and so this course
is really bringing these sort of two
normally quite separate ideas and
bringing them together in a way because
there's a lot of need to do so so again
this is the first course ever taught on
this topic there really isn't a prior
model for how to teach this so the
approach that we're taking is we're
going to have a lot of examples that
show how people use this technology and
hopefully see that and then we'll also
have some theory and as well as a lot of
examples and so hopefully through some
combination of those those different
types of teaching vehicles each of you
will be able to find something that is
helpful so the outline of today's
lecture is I'm going to go through an
example where we analyzed some citation
data so citation data is one of the most
common examples used in the field
because it's so readily available and so
easy to get and and so there's no issues
associated with it so you have lots of
academics analyzing themselves which is
of course very symmetric right and so
there's a lot of work on citation data
we take we are going to be looking at
citation citation data here but doing it
using the technology the deform
technology
that you all have access to doing it in
the way that that will work well there
which we think is is more efficient both
in terms of the performance you'll
receive get on your analytics and just
in terms of the total time it will take
you of course it does require a certain
level of comfort with linear algebra
that's sort of the mathematical
foundation of the class so we're going
to get right into it and I talked about
this in the in the previous lecture
these special schemas that we set up for
processing this kind of data that allow
us to essentially take any kind of data
and sort of pull it into from one basic
architecture that is really a good
starting point for for analysis so
here's a very classic type of data that
you might get in citation data here so
you in this particular data set we have
a universal identifier for each citation
so every single citation is just given
some index this data set and and we'll
have an author a doc ID and then a
reference doc ID so this basically is
the document ID of the document that's
being referenced in the and the one that
the reference is coming from that may
seem a little opposite but that's sort
of what it means and you can have
absences of both you can have references
where there is it's referring to another
document for which they have not
constructed some kind of document ID you
can also have references that are within
a document that just for some reason
other doesn't have a document ID as well
so I think the important thing to
understand here is that this kind of
incompleteness you know on a on a on a
data set which might be as clean a data
set as you would expect which is this
scientific citation data set this kind
of incompleteness is very normal we
always you never get data sets that are
even remotely perfect if you get data
sets that feel even like about eighty
percent solid that's you're doing very
well and it's very very common to have
data sets that are incomplete to have
mistakes null values mislabeled fields
etc etc it is just a natural part of the
process I think even though more and
more these data sets are created by
machines and you're hoping that would
eliminate some of those issues well the
machines have the same problems and they
can make mistakes on much larger scale
more quickly than then humans can so so
incompleteness definitely exists um we
pull this data into this this data is a
sort of a standard you know SQL or
tabular format here in which you have
records and columns and then values and
what we generally do is pull it into
what we call this exploded schema where
we have we still use the records those
are the row keys we create column keys
which are essentially the column label
and the column value appended together
so every single unique value will have
its own column and then we sort of build
it out that way and this creates this
very very large sparse structure which
once we store the transpose of that in
our database as well we get essentially
constant access to any string constant
time access to any string in the
database so we can now look up any
author very quickly any document very
quickly any record very quickly and so
it's a very natural schema for handling
this kind of data typically we just hold
the value one in the actual value of the
database we can we can put other numbers
in there but it generally should be a
number that you would never want to say
job because in in in in many of the data
sets that we have or the databases are
working with they can look up a row key
or with the schema you know a column key
very quickly but to look up a value
requires a complete reversal of the
table which is by definition very
expensive so there's definitely
information you can put in there but
just generally information you would
never want to really look up in addition
for this particular data set we have
some fields that are quite long and so
we might have the fully formatted
reference which in a journal article can
be quite long you know if it's got the
full name and the journal volume and
maybe all the authors and all that stuff
that can be quite long it's very
unstructured we might have the title we
might have the abstract these are long
longer blobs of data that we may be our
other data set essentially has extracted
all the key information from that but
often we still want to have access to
this information as a complete sort of
uninterruptedly so if you actually find
a record you're like well I'd like to
see the abstract as it was actually in
the journal formatted as it was in the
journal because a lot of times when you
pull this stuff out and do keywords you
might lose punctuation capitalization
other types of thing that just make it
generally easier to read but don't
really help you with indexing so we
actually recommend that that kind of
information be stored in a completely
separate table a traditional table which
would just be some kind of roki and then
the actual reference with the values
there you're never going to search the
contents of this but this allows you to
to at least have access to the day to
the data so this is sort of a small
addition to our standard
schema where we have the exploded schema
with all the sort of information that we
would ever want to search on with its
transpose which gives us very fast
search you might have an additional
table which just stores the data in a
RAW format separately you can look it up
quickly but it won't get in the away it
won't get in the way of any researches
the the problem can be if you're doing
searches and you have very large fields
mixed in with very small fields it can
become a performance bottleneck to be
handling these at the exact same time
another table that we used in this data
set which was to essentially index all
the words in the title and the abstract
and there n Gramps and so you you know
the one gram would just be the
individual words and a title if a word
appeared in a title you would create a
new column for that word with respect to
that reference an Engram would be word
pairs a trigram would be all words that
occur together in threes and on and on
and on and so often for text analytics
you want to store all of these and
essentially you might have here an input
data set with various identifiers a
title that consists of a set of words
and abstract that consists of set of
words and then we create typically what
we would do is we would say for the word
the one gram of the title a we might
format it like this and then here we
might hold where that appeared in the
document so this allows you to
essentially come back and reconstruct
the original document so that's not
something we that's a perfectly good
example of something that we don't tend
to need to search on which is the exact
position of a word in a document we
don't tend to really care that the word
was in the eighth position or the 10th
position or whatever so we can just
create a list of all these
these values in that way if you want to
then later reconstruct the original text
you can do that between a column and its
positions you have enough information to
do that so that's an example of another
type of schema that we admit and how we
handle this type of data for doing these
types of searches and now it makes it
very easy to say show me if I want to
look up please give me all documents
that had the the word d this this this
word d in the abstract I would simply go
over here fine look up the roki get get
get get these two columns and then I
could take those two column labels and
then look them up here and I would get
all the end grams or I could then take
those those rope keys and look them up
in any of the previous tables and get
that information so that's kind of what
you can do there and going over this
kind of quickly the examples go through
this in very specific detail but there's
kind of just showing you how we tend to
think about these data sets in a way
that's very flexible but showing you
some of the nuances it's not just the
one table it ends up being two or three
tables but still that that really covers
what you're looking for again the when
you're processing data like this you're
always thinking about a pipeline + d 4 m
the technology to talk about only one
piece of that pipeline we're not saying
that the technologies we're talking
about our cover every single step of
that pipeline so in this particular
dataset that we had which I think was
150 gigabyte data set so step one was
getting a hard disk drive sent to us and
copying it it came as a giant XML zip
file obviously a dumb uncompressed so we
the zip file we uncompressed it and then
from they
are we had to write a parser of the XML
that then spat that out into just a
series of triples that then could be
inserted into our database the way we
want well d forum is very good for sort
of developing how you're going to want
to parse those triples initially if
you're going to do a high volume parsing
of of data I would really recommend
using like a low-level language like C
it generally see is an outstanding
language for doing this very sort of
repetitive monotonous part parsing it
has excellent support for things like
XML and other types of things and it
will run as fast as you can and it's
generally yeah you had a bright writing
more code to do that it tends to be kind
of a do once type of thing you actually
do it more than once usually to get it
right but it's nice when I think our
parser the code that we wrote in C++
could take this several hundred mega
gigabytes of XML data and convert it in
triples you know in under an hour and so
that's that's a nice thing in other
environments if you if you try and do
this and say in Python or other types of
thing or even in d4 m at high volume
it's going to take a lot longer so the
right tool for the job it will take you
more lines of code to do it but we have
found that it's usually a worthwhile
investment because it can take a long
time once we have the triples typically
what we then do is read them in 2d for
em and construct associative arrays out
of them talked a little bit about
associative arrays last time all I'll
get to that again but these are
essentially a MATLAB data structure and
then and then we generally save them to
files we always recommend right before
you do an insert into a database often
even when you write I performance
parsers or if you're not writing in a
harbor the parsing can be a significant
activity and if you write the data out
in some sort of efficient file form and
right before you insert it if you ever
need to go back and reinsert the data
it's now very very fast thing to do
you'll often have databases that you get
especially during development they can
get cut
did you try and recover them but they
don't recover and again just knowing
that you have the parsed files laying
around someplace and you can just
process them whenever you want is a very
useful technique and usually is not such
a large expensive from a data
perspective and can allow you to serve
essentially reinsert the data at the
full rate the database can handle it as
opposed to having to redo your parsing
which sometimes can take ten times as
long we've definitely seen many folks
who they do full parsing text parsing
and Java or Python that often is 10
times slower than the actual insert part
of the database so it's nice to be able
to sort of check point that that data
and then from there we read the files in
and then insert them into our 322
database pairs the the keys and the
transpose the engrams and the transpose
and then the actual raw text its itself
I should also say keeping these
associative arrays around as files is a
is also very useful because the database
as we talked about before it's very good
if you have a large volume of data and
you want to look up a small piece of it
quickly if you want to reach reverse the
entire data set do some kind of analysis
in the entire data set that's going to
take about the same time as it took to
insert the data so you're going to be
having to pull all the data out if
you're going to be wanting to analyze
all of it there's no sort of magic there
so the database is very useful we're
looking up small pieces but if you want
to traverse the whole thing in which
case having those files around is a very
convenient thing if you're like I'm
going to traverse all the data my mind
as well just begin with the files and
traverse them and that's a very easy the
file system will read it in much faster
than the database that the bandwidth of
the file systems are much higher than
databases and it's also very easy to
handle in a parallel way you just send
step you know different processes parts
prosze in reading in different files so
if you're going to be doing something
that traverses an entire vol set of data
we really recommend that you you know
might do that in files in fact we even
see folks it's like well I might have a
query that requires three or four
percent of the data well then we would
recommend oftentimes if you know you're
going to be working on that same data
set over and over again queering it out
of the database saving to a set of files
and then just working with those files
over and over again now you never have
to deal with the Layton sees or other
issues associated with the database
you've completely isolated yourself from
that so databases are great you need to
use them the right thing but the file
system is also great and often in the
kind of work that we do that algorithm
development people do testing and
developing on the files is often better
than then using the database as your
sort of fine-grained rudimentary access
type of type of thing so cover that so
this particular dataset had 42 million
records and just to kind of show you um
how long it took using the pipeline we
uncompressed the xml file in one hour so
it's just running gzip our parser that
converted the XML binary structure in
two triples using seeps this was written
in C sharp was two hours so that's you
know very very nice we could as we debug
the parser you know we could rewrite it
and not have to worry about oh my
goodness this is going to be days and
days the constructing of the d4 m
associated raised from the triples took
about a day it just kind of shows you
there and then inserting the triples
into a key melot the this is us this was
a single node database very not a
powerful computer it was a dual core
circa 2006 server but we sustain an
insert rate of about 10,000 a hundred
thousand entries per second which is
extremely good for this particular
database which was accumulo so inserting
the keys took about two
answering the text took about one day to
entering the engrams took about ten days
in this particular data set we ended up
not using the engrams very much in this
particular to said mostly the keys and
so they're your that gives you an idea
the database itself is running in
parallel you can increase those insert
rate significantly but these are the
basic sort of single node insert
performance that we tend to see yes
question over here ah yes so I talked
about that a little bit in the first
class so a key melot is a type of
database called a triple store or
sometimes called a no sequel database um
it's a new class of database that's
based on the architecture published in
the Google BigTable paper which is about
five or six years old there's a number
of databases that have been built with
this technology it sits on top of a file
system infrastructure called Hadoop and
it's a very very high performance
database for what it what it does and
it's and that's the database that we use
here and it's open source a part of the
Apache project you know you can down
download it and at the end of the class
will actually be doing examples working
with databases we are developing an
infrastructure or part of ll grid to
host these databases so you don't really
have to kind of mess around with the
details of them and our hope is to have
that infrastructure ready by the last
two classes so you guys can actually try
it out so so the next thing we want to
do here is after we built these
databases i want to show you how we
construct grafts from this exploded
schema um formally this exploded schema
is what you would call an incidence
matrix so in graph theory graphs
generally can be represented as two
different types of matrix an adjacency
matrix which is a matrix where each row
and column is a vertex and then if
there's an edge between two vertices
they'll be
value associated with that generally
very sparse in the types of data sets
that we work with that is great for
covering certain types of graphs it
handles directed graphs very well it
does not handle graphs with multiple
edges very well it does not handle
graphs with hyper edges these are edges
that connect multiple vertices at the
same time and the data that we have here
is very much in that latter category a
citation or is essentially as a hyper
edge or this type in it basically one of
these things it connects a document with
sets of people with sets of titles with
sets of all different types of things so
it's a very very rich edge that's
connecting a lot of vertices and so a
traditional adjacency matrix doesn't
really capture it so that's why we store
the data as an incidence matrix which is
essentially one row for each edge and
then a cut and then you know and then
the columns are vertices and then you
basically have information that shows
which vertices are connected by that
edge so that's how we store the data you
know sort of a lossless fashion and we
have a mechanism for storing it and
indexing it fairly fairly efficiently
that said the types of analyses we want
to do ten to very quickly get us to
adjacency matrices I almost for those of
you who are familiar with radar this is
probably the only place where I could
say that on I almost think of one is
kind of the voltage domain in the other
the power domain you do lose information
when you go to the power domain but
often to make progress on your analytics
you need to that's just you have to do
that and so the adjacency matrix is a
formal projection of the incidence
matrix you essentially by multiplying
the incidence matrix by itself or
squaring it can get can get the the
adjacency matrix so let's look at that
so here's an adjacency matrix of this
data that shows the source document and
the cited site cited document and so
this just shows what what we see in this
dick corner up here if you see my mouse
going up here scream so we'll stay stay
in the safe area so this is the source
document and this is the sighted
document this is a significant subset of
this data set I think it's only a
thousand records a random sample I
showed you the real full dataset
obviously it would just be solid blue um
the the the the source document ID tends
to increase you know is decreasing in in
you know basically newer documents are
at the bottom older documents at the top
I assume everyone can know why we have
this sharp edge boundary here you can't
cite future documents right this is the
the the Einstein de vent cone of this
data set right you can't cite documents
into the end of the future so that's why
we have that that boundary there and you
can almost see it here you see and I
don't think that's just not the glues
you see how it's getting its denser here
and sparser here which just shows as
documents get published over time they
get cited less and less going into the
going into the future I think one
statistic is that if you eliminated self
citations most published journal
articles are never cited so so thank God
for self citation so this shows the
degree distribution of this data will
get into this in grudge greater detail
but this just shows here on this small
subset of data basically for each
document we count how many times it was
cited so these are documents that are
cited more and then we count how many
documents have that number of citations
so these are the documents is 10 to the
0 is basically documents that are cited
once this shows the number of documents
in this set here which was you know was
a twenty thirty forty thousand that have
one citation and then going on down here
to the one that is cited the most this
is what is called a power law
distribution basically it just says most
things are not cited very often and some
things are cited a long time you see
there's out approximately linear
negative slope in a log-log plot this is
something that we see all the time I
should say in what we call subsampled
data where essentially the space of
citations has not been fully sampled if
people stopped publishing alright and we
created new documents and all citations
only or older things then over time you
would probably see this thing begin to
take on a bit more of a bell-shaped
curve ok but as long as you're an
expanding world then you will get this
type of power law and a great many of
the data sets that we tend to work with
fall in this category and in fact it's
it's if you see if you work with data
that is a byproduct of artificial foot
human-induced phenomena this is what you
should expect and if you don't see it
then then you you kind of want to
question what's going on there there's
usually something going on there so so
those are some overall statistics those
are two things that we tip the adjacency
matrix and the degree distribution or
two things that we that we often look at
I'm going to sort of move things forward
here and talk about the differ
types of adjacency matrix we might
construct from the incidence matrix so
in general uh the adjacency matrix is
often denoted a devoted denoted by the
letter A and incidence matrices you
think we might use the word the letter I
but I has obviously been taken in matrix
theory so we tend to use the letter e
sometimes we it says you know for the
edge matrix so I used e is the sir this
is the associative array representation
of my edge matrix here and if I want to
find the author author correlation
matrix I just basically can do e starts
with author transpose times e starts
with author so basically this gets the
starts with author gets the gets the
part of the incidence matrix that has
just the authors I now have an
associative array of just authors and
then I square it with itself and you get
obviously a square symmetric matrix that
is dense along the diagonal because
every single document you know the
author appears with itself and then jus
this just shows you which authors appear
with which other offer authors so if two
authors appeared on the same article
article together they would get a dot
and so there's a very classic type of
graph the co-author graph its will
studied you know has a variety of
phenomena associated with it and here
it's constructed very simply from this
matrix matrix multiply I'm going to call
this sort of the inner square so we
actually have a shortcut for this in
indy form called square in so square in
means the matrix transpose times itself
it's sort of has an inner product we
feel to it no one has their name
associated with this product seems like
someone missed an opportunity there to
to you know some all the special
matrices are named after Germans and so
someone someone some German missed an
opportunity there back in the early days
so we maybe we can call it the inner
kapner product and would sufficiently
spirit a spirit like like the hadamard
product which I always have to look up
and here's the outer product so this
shows you the distribution of the
documents that share common authors so
it's the same so that's that's it just
sort of [ __ ] what I'm trying to show you
these adjacency matrices are formally
projections of the incidence matrix onto
a subspace and whether you do the inner
squaring or the outer squaring product
those are both have valuable information
one of them showed us which authors have
have have published together the other
one shows us which documents have common
authors both very legitimate pieces to
analyze and in each case we've lost some
information by constructing it but
probably out of necessity we have to do
this to make to make progress on the
analysis what we're doing and continue
it we can we can look at the
institutions so here's the inner
institution squaring a product and so
this shows you which institutions you
know are on the same paper and then
likewise this shows us which documents
share the same institution the same
thing with keywords okay which keywords
are shared you know which pairs of
keywords occur in the same document
which documents share the same keywords
etc etc etc typically when we do this
matrix multiply if we have the value be
a one then actually the value of the
result will be the count so this would
show you how many keywords
are shared by the document or in the
previous one how many times a pair of
keywords appear in the same document
together again valuable information for
constructing analytics and so these
these these these inner and outer Kepner
products or whatever we want to call
them are are very useful in that and
that in that regard so the now we're
going to turn a little bit take a little
bit of a turn here this is really going
to lead you up into the examples so
we're going to get back into this point
I made and kind of revisit it again
which is the the issues associated with
adjacency matrix multi edge graphs and
those types of things I think I already
talked about this just to remind people
here's a graph a directed graph okay
we've numbered all the vertices this is
the adjacency matrix of that of that
graph so basically two vertices have an
edge they get a dot the fundamental
operation of graph theory is what we
call breadth-first search so you start
at a vertex and then go to its neighbors
following the edges the fundamental
operation of linear algebra is is is
vector matrix multiply so by construct a
vector with a value in the in a
particular vertex and I do the matrix
multiply I find the edges and I result
in the the neighbors and so you have
this formal duality between the
fundamental operation of graph theory
here which is a breadth-first search and
linear algebra and so this is
philosophically how we will think about
that I think we've already shown a
little bit of that when we talk about
these projections from incidence
matrices 222
adjacency matrices and again why so so
to get into that a little bit further
and make that bring that point home you
know the traditional graph theory that
we are taught in graph theory courses
tends to focus on what we call directed
I mean sour undirected unweighted graphs
so these are graphs with with vertices
and you just say whether there's a
connection between vertices and you may
not have any information about you know
there's multiple connections between a
vertices and you certainly can't do
hyper edges and sort of this gives you
this very black-and-white picture of the
world here which is not really what what
the world really looks like and in fact
there's a painting courtesy of a friend
of mine who's an artist who does this
this type of painting I tend to like it
and this this is the same painting you
know what I show before Votto really
looks like okay and what you see is that
this is really more representative the
true world just drawing some straight
edge lines with colors on a canvas we
already have gone well beyond what we
could easily represent with undirected
unweighted graphs first of all our edges
in this case have color we have five
distinct colors which is information
that would not be caught captured in the
tradition traditional unweighted
undirected graph representation we have
20 distinct vertices here so I've
labeled every intersection or ending of
a line as a vertex so we have five
colors and 20 distinct vertices we have
12 things that we really should consider
to be multi edges okay these are
essentially multiple edges that connect
the same vertices and I've labeled them
by their color here
we have 19 hyper edges these are edges
that fundamentally connect more than one
vertex so if we look at this example
here p3 connects this vertex this vertex
this vertex and this vertex with one
edge we could of course topologically
say well this is the same you know the
same as just having an edge from here to
here here here here but that's not
what's really going on we are throwing
away information if we decompose that
finally we often have a concept of edge
ordering the order that the lines are
drawn here is is actually you ordered
that the line is drawn here you can
infer just from the layering of the
lines that certain edges occur before
others and ordering is also very
important and anyone I guess what color
was the first color of this painting
when the artist started they painted one
color first anyone want to guess what
that color was what Becca it was orange
it was orange and I would never guess
that except by talking to the artist
which is which is which I found
interesting and it shows you and when
she was telling me how she did it was so
counterintuitive to to to sort of kind
of maybe the perception of the work
which i think is is very very
interesting
so if you were to represent this in a
standard graph you would create 53
standard edges right you would you would
say this this this hyper edge here we
would break up into three separate edges
this hyper edge you would break up into
two separate edges etc etc 253 standard
edges so one of the basic observations
is that you know the standard edge
representation the fragments are hyper
edges a lot of information is lost the
diagraph representation compresses the
multi edges and a lot of information is
lost the matrix representations drops
the edge labels and a lot of information
is lost and so and the standard graph
representing drops is the edge order and
again more information loss so we really
need something better than the
traditional way to do that and so the
solution to this problem is to use the
incidence matrix formulation where we
assign every single edge a label a color
an order that it was laid down and then
for every single vertex ok we can just
so this is this this edge be one is blue
it's the it's in the second order group
and it's connects these three vertices
and you see various structures here
appearing for the different types of
things so this is how we would represent
this data as an incidence matrix in a
way that preserves all the information
so that's really kind of the power of
the incidence matrix approach to this
all right so that actually brings us to
the end of the first oh so we have the
question here so the analysis you
typically do is you take projections
into adjacency matrices yeah yeah so
this way you can you're preserving the
ability to do all those projections you
know and it's not to say sometimes the
right thing to do isn't be like
sometimes to make progress if your data
sets are large you're just forced you
have to just make some projections to
get started you know sometime
you know I mean theoretically one could
argue that the right way to proceed is
you you have the incidence matrix you
derive the analytics you want you know
maybe you use adjacency matrices an
analytic intermediate step but then once
you've figured out the analysis you then
go back and make sure that the analytic
runs just on the raw incidence matrix
itself and save yourself the time of
actually constructing the adjacency
matrix sometimes this space is so large
though it can be difficult for us to get
our minds around it and sometimes it can
be useful just like you know what I
really think that these projections are
going to be useful ones to get started
rather than trying to just get lost in
this force sometimes it better is like
I'm going to start by projecting you
know I'm going to create a few of these
adjacency matrices to get started make
progress may do my analytics and then
figure out if I need to fix it from
there because working in this space
directly can be a little bit tricky
every single analysis it's like working
in the voltage domain you're constantly
having to keep sort of extra theoretical
machinery around and sometimes to make
progress you're better off just going to
the power domain making progress and
maybe discover later if you can if you
can if you can fix it up you know doing
other types of things so are there other
questions before we come to the end of
this part of the lecture great okay
thank you so we'll take a short break
here and then we'll proceed to the demo
there is a sign-up sheet here if you
haven't signed up please write it down
apparently this is extremely important
for the accounting purposes of the
laboratory so I would encourage you to
do that so that will will will start up
again in about five minutes